foreign
[Music]
staff have voted and deliberated and we
have decided our game of the year for
2022 and
actually it was quite a runaway Victory
record time
um yeah I mean like it was quick but
a lot of the hard work was ahead of the
actual discussion right because we
collate the the uh votes and then we
have a system where we wait it depending
on where it appears in each person's
individual list etc etc they want to
give away too much of the secret sauce
but
this game was by far ahead of pretty
much everything else yeah a country mile
some might say the discussion around it
was pretty much a
it was it was a given we all knew it was
going to be contender
not only a contender but a big game both
in terms of you know what we like around
the office but also in terms of the
discourse yeah and what you know people
were going to be talking about when it
released earlier this year what do you
think is the thing that made it set it
apart for it to be so slow so easily
slide into our number one spot I think
the most interesting part of it is like
the major not worry about like the
consideration we had to factor in was it
came out very early in the year and
games that come out super early in the
year they kind of naturally have a
uphill struggle of making it to that top
of the list recency bias and also like
there's so much space for people to put
out games and improve them and react to
them and that kind of stuff so the fact
that it people were as passionate about
it at the end of the year as they were
at the beginning says a lot about it I
think yeah it wasn't a question for me
we filled out our top 10 Elden ring was
there right away it was usually I work
backwards when I make my personal list
but this time I worked from one because
of Elden ring easy me too yeah I
I'm a I like uh sort of the idea from
soft games more than I think I enjoy
playing them because I'm not good I'm
not good enough for a lot of the games I
mean well I mean
um but you know when it comes to Sakura
I could never really get the Knack up
and I was feeling a little bit
discouraged and so Elden ring being this
huge open world game
and the fact that I devoured it
platinumed it
um you know did pretty much everything I
could in that game was it came as a
surprise to me and I didn't anticipate
an open world game
to keep me as hooked as it did all the
way through I thought that I would be
you know choice paralysis because there
was too much in there I thought I'd get
bored and it was the complete opposite
for me and it was such a memorable
experience we had such a great time like
constant message group threads Discord
threads Who's online who can help me
here who's doing this you know and it
became this game that was much bigger
than the experience I was
uh having yeah but it became a thing
that we were all kind of doing together
so what were your I I think for me it
was a so I I wrote this in my write-up
for the game which you can read now on
the website but I don't think there's
been a studio that's been as influential
on video games as from software has been
in the last say decade around that time
I think you can definitely put a bunch
of Studios up there
um but very few of them have been so
influential that they reshape entire
genres as well as kind of inspire
sub-genres which is what the from
software games don't forget like when
Dark Souls came out there were a lot of
Dark Souls copycats like pretty much
entire games were like reworking their
RPG systems to be more like Dark Souls
then you go to things like you know
beloved
um games like Hollow Knight and various
other you know 2D indie games
from software's design has had a like
momentous impact on the industry
but the more games they put out the more
I don't want to say ordinary the more
kind of like
understood they are the most people have
an idea of what and I think the thing
that they expect what I expected is like
they make great games they make great
games in a very specific way like
regardless of if it's Demon Souls Dark
Souls bloodborne sakuro they have a
certain design formula or like a set of
principles that they adhere to and a lot
of what makes their games impressive and
interesting is they have a very heavy
level of orchestration where it's like
they can control every variable they
know what a player is going to see when
they're going to see it how they're
likely to react to it how they're likely
to not react to it and they can play
with those kind of Dynamics to create
these environments it's kind of like
it's easier to make it interesting for
you to walk down a corridor than it is
to put you in a field so the worry
always was how do they evolve that they
can't just carry on doing that Sakura
was one step where they make it like
more combat focused and more like
mechanic focused even more control yeah
even more control too so like when they
were uh decided that they were going to
do an open world game and we heard it's
going to be an open world the big worry
was how do they have that level of
orchestration
and have that level of control over what
you see when you see and how you respond
to it and subverting that in a massive
environment when you can go away and do
anything and the answer was just make
everything amazing or like just make
everything as good as you can so that no
matter where you turn you're having some
sort of meaningful interaction with the
world or you're having some sort of
meaningful moment that you can that will
be memorable to you and that's what
eldering excels at right it doesn't
matter if you're in a dungeon it doesn't
matter if you're going to a legacy
dungeon and like Stormville or something
like that or just a small dungeon it's
never just straightforward the most
straightforward is get it gets is like
you fight through a dungeon and you get
an item at the end and usually the item
is of some value to you but like on the
other specs end of the spectrum like you
get massive multi-layered huge
environment of a castle and then at the
end of it there's a boss fight and you
get some meaningful upgrades and you get
some story out of it and you can chart
your own path through that world and
approach anything exactly how you want
so the big issue with open World Games
is everything has in order to make them
big is everything has a kind of
uniformity a plainness to it you see
that and there's a formulaic nature to
it we see that with Ubi games where it's
like here's the three types of my
checklist yeah here's the three types of
game missions that all design missions
that we have you're going to do these
over and over again everywhere or you
know breath of the wild has it as well
breath of wild an incredible game but
like there's a uniformity to those
shrines and it needed to be that way
element ring definitely has some of that
uniformity but it does such a good job
at having enough diversity that you
don't feel that uniformity and that is I
think one of the most amazing things
about about it you always feel like
you've got something more for yourself
something unique and you always feel
like I need to tell someone about this
even if you know deep down that they
probably had something similar somewhere
else
so I think like that level of authorship
is incredible and it's one of the things
that really made it stand out all this
time later yeah you touched on it but I
I was definitely feeling sort of a uh
open world fatigue I guess and and when
I heard that this was going to be an
open world from software game I was a
little concerned because as you're
saying I really liked those not linear
but very controlled spaces that you were
supposed to go through in a in a
particular way but I think Elden ring
just right when you get out of that
first Tomb and you see the world before
you in the map hide like it doesn't tell
you everything that you're going to see
it it picks and chooses the information
that it wants to show you and it feels
like just an incredibly massive
Adventure where you can choose where you
want to go like what weapons you want to
use what you want to take on you could
stumble into an area that you're just
not ready for could back off or you
could find a way to cheese your way
through it or you know you could call in
some friends and get through that that
dungeon like that and I think it's just
that level of Freedom that has always
been a kernel of those games right like
that's always been an important part in
terms of like what build you're going to
use how are you going to play what what
weapon are you going to use what magic
you're going to use but I feel like
it starts with that but then it expands
throughout the entire world and it just
it's such a memorable Adventure I'm
always like super curious to see how
people got through a certain area like
how did you get through Stormville
Castle how did you beat how did you beat
this boss how did you beat that boss and
and just those conversations make that
game so much more than just a game for
me and like I've I've had some of the
most memorable gaming experiences of all
my old my whole life playing that game
like I was playing obviously before
everyone else when I was reviewing it
and
the the kind of experience of opening a
chest and suddenly being in caled and
being like yeah and not understanding
what's going on understanding like and
having those annoying bugs like doing
their homing attacks being stuck and
like being like I'm not leaving here I'm
fighting my way out of this like that
going into that like the fact that one
thing that you mentioned was it doesn't
tell you that much it tells you
basically nothing like it's like figure
this stuff out on your own here's it's
got the um guidance of Grace which is
like go in this general direction and
that's about it so that feels
antithetical to literally how every open
world game is designed I would guess
there's probably designers out there who
would say if you want your players to
see the content you're making don't do
this and this feels like a very kind of
like opposite direction approach for
them but because they do that you can
have moments where you get into a lift
and the lift goes down and down and down
and down and then you appear in an
underground civilization basically with
its own starry night and you're just
like jaw dropping Vista in this area and
you're like fighting your way through
that and
it's it's like this I described it
designed by subtraction and I said in my
review that it's going to be remembered
for what it doesn't do as much as what
it does and I really like stand by that
to this day I really hope it's some kind
of I mean you know
in a cyclical way this conversation come
around where it's like so many people
and so many different designers and
developers have taken a lot from Souls
games and one of the things I think has
happened particularly with open world
design is that they are so scared of you
dropping off whereas Elden ring proves
that you can trust the player as long as
you create a world that is interesting
enough and I really hope that is
something that uh is taken from this
game because I've similarly to both of
you I've never felt such an ex like even
with breath of the wild it's a fantastic
game I love it but I never felt like the
regions were as distinct or if the
discovery the promise of Discovery was
as important or as interesting in Elden
ring and you know couple with the fact
that
I could just sort and board it if I
wanted to or I could just take on magic
or I could just do this I could just do
that and all this little quality of life
upgrades that maybe would have been
slightly off-putting to me you know I
streamed trying to play Dark Souls and
going back to Dark Souls 1 after playing
Elden ring is like fantastic yeah I have
no idea why in my whole brain but the
way that you know they just make these
little tweaks and like getting rid of
weapon durability for example you know
and just everything it can do to push
you out into that world I feel like
Elden ring does and I think it is such a
truly special experience and there has
been so much discourse I feel like
everything that can be said about Elden
ring probably has been I think yeah
there's there's a trust too that I have
in from software and I imagine a lot of
players too I feel like from software is
uniquely positioned to remove a lot of
that info because the players know that
they are going to get something
surprising something interesting
something different than what they might
see in other games and I think it
challenges them something that
challenges them yeah so like
it's interesting because for a lesser
game I may want more guidance on where
to go what to do next but when it comes
to from software and just that Mastery
that they have I
I know I'm going to see it because I
want to see it and that is what's
propelling me it's not it feels very
organic yeah the kind of like Rules of
Engagement are laid out one by the
studios Legacy the history and also at
the very start of the game like if you
came into that world and you were
expecting it to be one thing and a game
of certain way and then it was something
like not giving you the information that
you need to play the way it's designed
to be that's a different thing and I
think that one thing that you touched on
Lucy that's really important is like
developers spend so much time and it's
not their fault
um developers spend so much time
creating these vast worlds that are like
truly incredible and feel so immersive
and then kind of like rubber meets the
road and they have to make a call on how
people navigate through that and often
the smartest way to do it is to gamify
it which is kind of removes that
immersion and it kind of undoes a lot of
the hard work of creating this world
that feels
livable and real and realistic by
turning that into a like a video game
and from software like Jake said are in
a position where they can be like no
we're not going to do that we're going
to do things that others will tell us is
antithetical to good game design but we
can do that because we've trained our
audience and also not to understate the
actual design and balance that goes into
making sure that you're still having a
good time even if you don't have the
context to know how from software does
their thing you can approach a stonevale
castle and realize I can't beat this
boss or I can't get through this and
there are ways to completely circumvent
it if you want to or you can go do
something else you're never required to
be each of the album Lords you just need
to be a few of them and get what you
need out of it so there's definitely
that kind of like smart design as well
as the braveness and boldness to just go
there in their own way
um and we talked about it and I talked
about it and also in this discussion
like from software I think are the most
influential game developer of the past
decade and the question was can they
remain that and I think Ellen ring is
the game that shows they can still be as
influential now as they were when they
released demon souls and dark souls and
if that doesn't own you a game of the
year award I don't know what else it can
so even before releasing the game many
fans talk about this game a lot and that
helped you know Help Us increasing our
motivation during the development and
after releasing the game many fans of
course played a lot you know give us a
good reputation about it and you know
that leads to us at least even this kind
of great award from uh you know the game
spot so once again we want to say thank
you so much to the other fans out there
thank you